whatever would stuffy the country car
Chester honey lipstick says Volvo is
known for building robust cars like the
second generation of the xc90 it's in
the top class of SUVs the first
generation Volvo xc90 first hit the
market in 2002 Volvo stuck with a design
for 13 years that didn't go down well
with some dealers who prefer to see
models change every 6 or 7 years so
Volvo came out with the second
generation as competition for the BMW x5
and Audi q7 honey points out that this
xc90 is powered by a four-cylinder
engine with a capacity of 2 litres
various performance and fuel options are
available there's even a plug-in hybrid
but he thinks a car this big should
really have a v6 engine that is a POSIX
krinkle it's the ultimate role of work
but does the smaller engine mean that
the xc90 somehow has less to offer we're
going to test the d5 AWD model which
features four-wheel drive
[Music]
the Volvo our design gives this car a
performance inspired look and feel with
the enhanced Polestar version of the
engine the xc90 can jump from 0 to 100
km/h in 7.7 seconds and hit a top speed
of 220 kilometers an hour
Rahmi says that this xc90 has been
outfitted with pole star performance
optimizing software which boosts engine
power by a whopping 4 kilowatts that
costs an extra 1200 euros but it's good
value for money the software not only
boost power but also torque to 500
Newton meters instead of 480 you can
really feel the difference 1500 rpms can
sure get this 2 ton vehicle moving our
test car was painted Sweden blue other
options besides color include 22 inch
rims this version of the xc90 is 15
centimeters longer than the previous
version and 2 centimetres wider
[Music]
Ronnie says the car's interior is really
comfortable
everything's where it's supposed to be
nice and tidy the controls are all here
on the big touchscreen he thinks it all
looks great but it's a little awkward at
first until you figure out where
everything is there are more apps here
than Ronnie has on his phone and if you
don't find the heater app quickly you'll
either freeze or roast and maybe
quibbling but he'd still rather have a
few proper push buttons okay it's making
a whole new voters month a sonic
refurbished
Ronnie really likes the Bowers & Wilkins
sound system whether it's 1400 watts and
20 speakers keynote Saul's instead the
interior is quite posh there's carbon
fiber trim stainless steel and leather
everywhere you look
a 24 centimeter touchpad allows you to
control just about everything except the
basics there's lots of room in here too
even with five passengers and there's an
add-on option for a third row of seats
[Music]
demo mommy says that this model with a
d5 diesel engine the are design features
Pulstar optimization and a few other
extras will cost around 90,000 euros
this car has a lot to offer a powerful
engine a streamlined chassis and a
world-class sound system and the seats
are really comfortable it's a table you
know Ronnie says the Volvo xc90 is a
first class car and he can't wait to see
what Volvo comes up with next